The creature let out an unmistakable squeal
of rage as Stimulus Y835 took effect. Doctor
Kristiansen pressed his face up against the glass,
eager to see the results. It had to work this
time, it simply had to. He was certain that this
attempt would make all the other failures worth
it, and he’d once again prove the Foundation’s
faith in him to be well-placed. SCP-5683 shrieked
a loud, insect-like sound that would have normally
made the blood run cold of anyone that heard it.
But to Doctor Kristiansen, it was like music – a
monster’s dying fanfare to mark his success. Soon,
he’d be the researcher who neutralized not one,
but two tenacious, highly adaptable anomalies. The
senior researcher could feel his heart racing
as the deadly giant spider started to twitch,
then burst into two identical entities.
The pair of arachnid anomalies had reacted
much like the results of the tissue sample
test conducted earlier, dividing into two
separate organisms. Kristiansen held his breath
– the tissue samples had destroyed each other,
attacking and injecting the other with lethal
doses of venom. Surely, he reasoned, duplicating
SCP-5683 into two would have the same result…
His heart sank as he watched one of the spider
creatures – the duplicate – perish almost
immediately. As it often did when presented
with human prey, SCP-5683 attacked using its
mandibles and impaled its copy with its front legs
to pin it in place. The clone had bitten back,
with Doctor Kristiansen already knew would have
granted SCP-5683 an immunity to its own venom.
Its powers of adaptation were fiercely,
frustratingly efficient, and nothing demonstrated
this more than the intense reaction from the man
tasked with destroying it. Doctor Kristiansen
hurled the nearest object – a coffee mug –
at the glass window of the observation room,
overlooking the testing chamber. He pounded
his fist against the glass, hardly with the
required force to cause damage, but enough to
send pain shooting down Kristiansen’s wrist, which
then nestled in his forearm; a reminder that the
experiment, like the others, had failed.
“Why can’t I destroy you?” he muttered
through clenched teeth, looking with hatred
at the enormous spider in the chamber below.
The directive had reached him the day
immediately after New Years’ Day 2020,
and straight from a member of the O5 Council, no
less. Their message expressed how impressed the
Council was with Doctor Kristiansen’s success with
the Doomsday Clock project, and how favorably his
name had been mentioned in Council meetings. This
boded well for the ambitious Foundation doctor;
he’d been hoping to snag the Director position
at Site 04 now that Director Bray had retired.
But there was one more test from the O5
Council. They wanted Doctor Kristiansen to
use the knowledge garnered during his previous
success to solve the SCP-5683 problem. If he
could successfully complete that assignment, it
would be his ticket to being promoted. With the
comfy role of Site Director and all its perks in
mind, Doctor Kristiansen accepted the assignment
from the Council to deal with SCP-5683.
SCP-5683 was quite the beast, not an
anomaly for those with intense arachnophobia.
The huge spider-like organism was extremely
hostile towards humans, and had to be kept in a
constant state of medical sedation. Otherwise,
it would relentlessly attempt to breach
containment and slaughter any and all
personnel in its path. What had made SCP-5683 such
a problem for the Foundation was the creature’s
ability to rapidly regenerate damage as well
as modify its own body in reaction to threats.
Much like a certain, particularly Hard to Destroy
Reptile, the spider-like entity could adapt itself
to become more resistant to any danger posed to
it. And, of course, this meant that the Foundation
needed this dangerous creature eradicated. The
frequent containment breaches and sheer number
of casualties caused by the arachnid anomaly were
significant enough to cause an increasing drain
on the SCP Foundation’s resources. So, with the
termination order coming from the very top, the O5
Council themselves, Doctor Kristiansen was tasked
with overseeing the neutralization of SCP-5683.
During an initial deliberation, Doctor
Kristiansen met with Researchers Miles and Hall,
Junior Researcher Silva, and Security Chief
Aday to discuss earlier attempts to terminate
SCP-5683. The new head of the termination project
was perturbed to learn that the research team
had little in the way of useful information to
offer, beyond what the Foundation already knew
about the creature. But Kristiansen decided some
basic stress testing would at least be a start.
After a successful tissue sample test,
wherein some of SCP-5683’s genetic material
was incinerated, Doctor Kristiansen tried
to simply destroy the spider with fire.
An understandable response, to say the least.
However, exposing SCP-5683 to temperatures of 850
degrees Celsius for just thirty seconds didn’t
quite yield the easy victory he’d hoped for.
The arachnid thrashed about and screeched in
reaction to the heat, only to rapidly develop
a form of armor plating covering its entire
body. The armor was comprised of an unknown,
unidentifiable substance, but it was
enough to prevent SCP-5683 from combusting.
Reconvening with the rest of the team,
Doctor Kristiansen hid his pride,
assuring everyone he was just trying to establish
a baseline during the previous test. Of course,
he hadn’t believed that terminating SCP-5683
with fire would be a success, or so he claimed,
hiding how much he’d longed for an easy solution
so he could snatch up the vacant Site 04 Director
position. But to ensure the others, Kristiansen
explained that he’d requisitioned some anomalous
materials from the O5 Council, that they’d
be using in their next termination attempts.
Nothing that was anomalous enough to require
containment, but toxic enough that they presented
a few options for destroying SCP-5683.
“Just for logging purposes, sir,
may I inquire about the specific substances we’re
shipping in?” Junior Researcher Silva had asked.
“Of course. Y220, Y835, and Y43,” Doctor
Kristiansen quickly recounted them all
from memory. “I’m told they should
be arriving within the week. I expect
each would be enough to do the job, but it’s
best to hedge our bets. This spider doesn’t
compare to the lizard, I’ll tell you that.”
Junior Researcher Silva seemed to take an interest
in what Doctor Kristiansen had just alluded to:
his previous work with ‘the lizard’. He probed
further about it, and Kristiansen gave a solemn
response. The aspiring Foundation Doctor recalled
an incident from a few years earlier during
his experimentation with SCP-682. Some of the
methods Doctor Kristiansen had opted to employ in
an attempt to destroy the Hard to Destroy Reptile
had led to a severe containment breach. When
describing it, he used the word ‘unpleasant’
perhaps out of guilt at how many personnel had
lost their lives due to his actions. Brushing
the topic aside, he urged his team to get on with
testing the new anomalous stimuli on SCP-5683.
Stimulus Y220 initially showed some
promise: during a Tissue Sample Test,
it successfully converted part of SCP-5683
into glass, which then violently exploded,
leaving nothing behind. But attempts to use
it to neutralize the creature itself quickly
quashed those promising results. Within nine
seconds of being exposed to Stimulus Y220,
SCP-5683’s body rapidly turned into glass. Around
eighty percent of its arachnid mass proceeded to
explode, shattering in all directions, sending
clear shards showering over the testing chamber.
As he watched, Doctor Kristiansen allowed himself
to believe that this was mission accomplished,
that he’d successfully terminated SCP-5683.
But his celebration was premature; the spider
quickly began reconstituting itself, its body
regenerating within the space of thirty seconds.
After testing with both Stimuli Y220 and Y835,
Doctor Kristiansen’s frustration seemed to be
increasing with each failed attempt. He knew
his promotion was within reach. And as far
as he could remember, he’d done good work with
damaging SCP-682. Why should eradicating this
anomalous spider be any different? However, it
was the test with Stimulus Y436 that enraged
the ambitious doctor. Expecting the anomalous
stimulant to turn SCP-5683 into a fine mist,
Kristiansen watched as the creature’s
body vanished, literally vaporizing,
changing states of matter to little more than
water in the air. Suddenly, every light in the
facility powered off, plunging the testing chamber
into darkness. When the lights came back on,
SCP-5683 was standing on all eight legs, right
where it had been mist only three seconds earlier.
The research team had gathered for another
mediation, and Doctor Kristiansen’s anger
still hadn’t subsided. He kicked a
chair to emphasize his frustration,
alarming Junior Researcher Silva, who urged him to
calm down. After eventually, cooling his temper,
Kristiansen made an announcement that caused
even greater concern to spread among the team.
“I’m requisitioning Y910.”
Researcher Hall and Researcher Miles objected,
trying to get Doctor Kristiansen to realize
that this course of action was excessive,
overkill even. But Kristiansen disregarded them,
standing by his latest method for terminating
SCP-5683. The Global Occult Coalition had
previously used Y910 to poison gods, he felt sure
that it would work on one anomalous giant spider.
His time was running short, Doctor Kristiansen
was aware that any day now, the O5 Council would
be appointing a replacement Director of Site 04,
and he wanted that promotion. And he didn’t seem
to care what corners he cut – and what risks he
took – to get there, even if it meant endangering
his researcher personnel. Doctor Kristiansen
declared that, in order to save time, he would
be bypassing tissue sample tests for termination
attempts. The longer it took to terminate the
anomalous arachnid, the more his window of
opportunity closed and the further the Director
position slipped from his fingertips. Accepting
full responsibility for the reckless decision and
anything that might go wrong, Doctor Kristiansen
wanted to use Stimulus Y910 directly on SCP-5683.
He urged the research team to make the necessary
preparations, unaware of what his decision would
lead to… and the chaos it had already caused.
The test was catastrophic. So much so that it
caused a containment breach. With SCP-5683 loose
and scuttling about the facility on its multiple
legs, Doctor Kristiansen and Junior Researcher
Silva were forced to rush to the secure bunker
on site for safety. Kristiansen was in a state
of panic, until he noticed something – and not
for the first time, either. He’d been detecting a
foul smell whenever he’d conducted the meetings to
discuss termination options. But the other members
of the research team had quickly explained it
was nothing more than repeated ‘accidents’ in
the cafeteria. But here was the stench again,
worse than ever. Yet, Junior Researcher Silva
brushed it off again, stating SCP-5683
must’ve gotten into the facility’s reactor.
The Junior Researcher quickly became inconsolable,
stating that the whole situation was his fault.
Doctor Kristiansen interjected, demanding to
know how it was, and what Silva had done to
cause this situation. He replied that it had
been his duty to oppose ill-advised actions,
and when Kristiansen had declared his intention
to use Y910, the Junior researcher hadn’t opposed
him. Shifting the blame from himself onto his
subordinate, Doctor Kristiansen chastised Silva
over how many personnel had died because of
the Junior Researcher’s refusal to do his
job – ignoring that it was Kristiansen’s own
ambitions that had led to the current chaos.
Refusing to be made a scapegoat, Doctor
Kristiansen vowed to pin the full culpability
for SCP-5683’s containment breach onto Junior
Researcher Silva, saying he’d tell the O5
Council the so-called ‘truth’ about what had
happened. But Silva pointed out there wasn’t
much likely the bunker would survive the reactor
overloading. He urged the ambitions Foundation
doctor to admit some responsibility of his own
for what had happened, but Kristiansen refused.
Suddenly, there came a thunderous banging at
the bunker door. A debilitating pang of fear
struck Doctor Kristiansen, causing him to scream
and retreat from the entrance, yelling ‘no’ and
‘please’ as if he was pleading with the universe
itself to spare him from the spider. Junior
Researcher Silva walked over to the bunker door,
just as strong, arachnid legs tore the heavy steel
bulkhead off its hinges like it was made of little
more than wet paper. Stood behind was SCP-5683,
the enormous spider skittering into
the bunker, screeching all the while.
Silva had put himself between SCP-5683 and
the ambitious Foundation doctor, whose hunger
for a promotion had led to all this carnage. The
Junior Researcher announced his noble intention to
sacrifice himself, occupying the creature while
he urged Kristiansen to run. The doctor shoved
Silva towards the spider and prepared to run…
Then, all of a sudden, SCP-5683 vanished.
Junior Researcher Silva told Doctor Kristiansen
he was disappointed, before Researcher Miles,
Researcher Hall, and Security Chief Aday all
entered the bunker through the torn-open hole
where the door had been. Kristiansen questioned
where SCP-5683 had gone, to which Silva explained
there was little reason to keep a dummy around
once it had served its purpose… as a substitute.
“You mentioned you worked with a lizard, sir,”
the Junior Researcher recounted. “That there was
a containment breach. If you don't terribly
mind me asking, how did you escape that
situation? It seemed quite lethal, didn't it?”
Afraid and confused, Doctor Kristiansen asked
where he was. Hall and Miles urged him not to ask
questions he already knew the answer to. Silva
explained who they all were: a Jury, specifically
Doctor Kristiansen’s Jury. And according to them,
the ambitious doctor had disgraced himself again.
Kristiansen had been there for a long time,
a considerably long time, reliving the same
events over and over again, with SCP-5683
acting as a substitute for SCP-682. It was the
same situation, he’d made the same decisions,
the same mistakes – and it had cost lives. Now,
Doctor Kristiansen was trapped in an endless loop,
penance for the casualties that had occurred at
his hands, all in the pursuit of his own selfish
personal gain. He asked the Jury how long he’d be
stuck there, a question Silva responded to with:
“Until you take responsibility, sir.”
Immediately, Doctor Kristiansen tried to
admit this had all been his fault. But he didn’t
mean it, not really. He hadn’t accepted blame,
he just wanted a quick and easy way out of the
loop; and the Jury of his deceased personnel knew
it. Kristiansen ran for the door in the hopes
of escaping his fate, futile as his chances
were. A black iron chain appeared from around the
corner and wrapped itself around the overambitious
doctor’s throat, ignorant of his pleas for
forgiveness. Saying he was sorry wouldn’t
bring back the people who’d died in service
of his aspirations to become a Site Director.
The chain dragged Doctor Kristiansen through the
facility at such a speed that he collided with
every wall, and every corner as he turned
sharply, pulled along the floor. But that,
and the walls quickly crumbled away, revealing a
sight that made Doctor Kristiansen start screaming
that it wasn’t his fault – and he never
really stopped. What followed involved a
great deal of blood and fire. Once it was over,
it left behind the same awful stench the doctor
had smelt before. And he’d soon be smelling
it again too, as the cycle repeated itself.
The directive had come straight
from a member of the O5 Council.
They were impressed with Doctor Kristiansen.
And the ambitious Foundation doctor had been
hoping to snag a Director position at Site 04.
But there was one final test: for Doctor
Kristiansen to solve the SCP-5683 problem.
Now check out “SCP-5000 WHY? - THE FULL
STORY COMPILATION” and “SCP-3023 - AND THEN
IT DECIDED TO BE AN ANGRY SPIDER” for more!